le livre voyageur vous connaissez le
principe consiste à laisser un livre à
l'endroit où on l'a terminé à café à
l'hôtel une gare le livre est mis à la
disposition d'un autre lecteur qui fait
la même chose et le livre voyage ces
deux dernière journée était consacrée à
cette pratique alors je sais en période
de confinement c'est pas la meilleure
idée mais ce principe peut être adapté
aux trajets courts et même très courts à
l'intérieur d'une même famille
c'est ce que je faisais quand mes
enfants étaient plus jeunes et c'est
ainsi par exemple que nous avons mis la
gloire de mon père je lis deux pages à
haute voix monfils récupère le livre en
est une
puis le plus jeune 5 à vue essayez vous
verrez c'est un vrai moment d'évasion
une capsule de déconfit n'est allé à
demain et n'oubliez pas il est encore un
peu trop tôt pour tourner la page
nous sommes tous confinés mais en
restant bien si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour ne rater aucune de ces
capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous et
activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain